Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui on va, enfin!
parler du Big Bang.
Alors oui, c'est un sujet
que j'ai déjà évoqué de nombreuses fois
dans d'autres vidéos,
mais j'ai décidé d'en faire
un épisode dédié
et je vais essayer de vous faire comprendre
du mieux possible
ce qu'est la théorie du Big Bang,
ce qu'elle dit
et aussi ce qu'elle ne dit pas
sur les origines de l'univers.
Alors à première vue, l'idée de Big Bang
paraît un peu folle,
est-ce que c'est vraiment de la science
est-ce que c'est pas plutôt de la philosophie
voire de la théologie?
On pourrait le penser, mais on va voir
que la notion de big bang est bien
un concept scientifique
qui est né principalement dans la première
moitié du 20e siècle,
et ce grâce à des progrès spectaculaires
aussi bien dans les théories physiques
que dans les observations astronomiques.
[Jingle]
Cette vidéo, j'aurais vraiment pu la
commencer par:
"de tout temps les hommes se sont demandé
d'où vient l'univers".
Pour le coup c'est un peu vrai, à peu
près toutes les cultures
et toutes les religions ont,
à un moment ou à un autre,
créé des cosmogonies c'est-à-dire
des récits mythologiques
destinés à expliquer l'origine
et la formation du monde,
et pourtant l'idée même de l'univers
tel qu'on se le représente aujourd'hui
est relativement récente.
Si je vous demande comment on pourrait
décrire l'univers connu de façon simple,
vous allez peut être me dire que
l'univers c'est plein de galaxies
qui contiennent chacune plein d'étoiles
et en fait cette vision de l'univers,
elle est très récente,
elle a à peine 100 ans.
Pendant longtemps on ne parlait pas
"des" galaxies, mais de LA galaxie,
le terme ne servait qu'à désigner uniquement
la nôtre: la Voie lactée.
On ne savait pas qu'il y avait
d'autres galaxies
et on pensait que la Voie lactée c'était
essentiellement l'ensemble de l'univers.
Alors oui, bien sûr, il y avait ces
quelques taches pâlottes
qu'on voyait à plusieurs endroits du ciel,
qu'on appelait des nébuleuses
et dont on ne savait pas trop
ce qu'elles étaient,
mais à part ça, on pensait qu'il n'y avait
que la Voie lactée
et les étoiles qu'elle contenait.
Et puis à force d'observations astronomiques
le doute s'est installé.
En 1912 l'astronome Vesto Slipher observe
la lumière émise
par certaines de ces nébuleuses et découvre
qu'elle possède un décalage de couleur,
c'est-à-dire que la lumière
que l'on reçoit d'elles
est plus rouge ou plus bleu que ce
qu'on attendrait.
Slipher interprète ça avec un analogue
de l'effet Doppler.
L'effet Doppler c'est ce qui modifie le son
perçu de la sirène des pompiers
selon que le camion s'approche
ou s'éloigne de nous,
plus aigu le camion s'approche,
plus grave il s'éloigne.
Avec la lumière c'est un peu pareil,
le décalage vers le rouge indique
qu'une nébuleuse s'éloigne
et Vesto Slipher constate que c'est le cas
de la majorité de celles qu'il observe,
et les vitesses sont relativement importantes,
plusieurs centaines de km par seconde
on commence alors à sérieusement douter de
la nature de ces nébuleuses.
Est-ce qu'elles appartiennent vraiment
à la Voie lactée?
Ou bien est-ce qu'il s'agit d'objets
astrophysiques beaucoup plus lointains?
À l'époque cette question agite les
scientifiques
et devient une controverse qui prend
un nom assez épique:
"le grand débat".
Eh bien le grand débat sera tranché
quelques années plus tard, en 1925
grâce à une mesure de l'astronome
Edwin Hubble,
celui ci observe la nébuleuse M31 située
dans la constellation d'Andromède
et estime qu'elle est située à environ
2 millions d'années-lumière de nous
et qu'il s'agit donc bien
d'une autre galaxie
extérieure à la Voie lactée
et très éloignée d'elle.
À ce moment là, on a vraiment réalisé que
l'univers était plus compliqué que prévu,
qu'il était constitué de différentes
galaxies très éloignées les unes des autres
et que manifestement ces galaxies bougeaient.
Alors en parallèle de tout cela, en 1915
Einstein avait publié sa théorie
de la relativité générale,
son but premier à l'époque était d'expliquer
de façon plus satisfaisante
la force de gravité et pour cela
il avait eu recours à une notion nouvelle:
"la courbure de l'espace-temps".
L'ingrédient essentiel pour comprendre
la relativité générale,
c'est cette idée que l'espace-temps
ne serait pas une sorte d'arène fixe,
statique dans laquelle se dérouleraient
les événements,
mais plutôt un objet dynamique doté
d'une courbure
et qui peut se déformer sous l'effet
de la matière,
Alors généralement pour expliquer
ça rapidement,
j'utilise une image de ce genre
où l'on voit un espace en deux dimensions,
une sorte de tissu, avec une grille
qui est déformée, courbée
et ça va affecter les trajectoires.
Alors cette image est assez pratique
pour parler de l'idée de courbure,
mais elle pose plusieurs petits problèmes.
Einstein et la relativité générale
nous disent:
"oubliez l'idée d'un espace fixe, immuable."
Alors pour illustrer ça, on prend l'image
d'une toile en deux dimensions
qui se déforme, bon ben OK, sauf que
cette toile, ben on la représente elle-même
dans un espace en trois dimensions
qui lui, est fixe et immuable,
donc ont trahi l'idée d'origine d'Einstein,
on fait revenir un espace fixe et immuable
de façon un peu détournée,
comme contenant de l'espace
courbe et déformé.
Alors c'est normal d'essayer de faire ça,
notre cerveau a énormément de mal à admettre
cette idée
que l'espace puisse ne pas être un truc
fixe et immuable,
donc on essaye à tout prix de s'y raccrocher
avec une image comme celle
de la toile déformée,
on arrive grâce à ça à s'imaginer
un espace courbe,
mais seulement s'il y a un espace
immuable autour, mais on a tort.
Pour bien comprendre le Big Bang, il faut
qu'on arrive à se débarrasser de ça,
il faut qu'on admette qu'on peut déformer
intrinsèquement l'espace,
sans avoir besoin de le plonger
dans un espace fixe plus grand.
Et donc pour ça, laissez tomber la toile,
on va essayer de regarder le problème
sous un autre angle
en oubliant un peu cette histoire
de courbure.
Imaginez un espace en deux dimensions,
ça marcherait pareil en trois dimensions,
mais c'est plus simple à dessiner,
je vais mettre une grille dessus et
considérer deux points de cet espace.
Donc les points 1 et 2, grâce à la grille
je peux leur donner à chacun
des coordonnées (x1 y1) et (x2 y2)
Maintenant imaginez que je souhaite calculer
la distance entre ces deux points,
c'est assez simple il suffit de faire
un coup de théorème de Pythagore,
regardez: je calcule l'écart entre les
deux coordonnées en x
on va noter ça delta x, et pareil
dans l'autre direction c'est delta y
Et là ben j'ai un triangle rectangle
et donc la distance entre mes deux points
c'est l'hypoténuse, donc simplement racine
de delta x au carré plus delta y au carré
jusqu'ici tout va bien, maintenant
je vais faire un truc
qui va vous sembler bizarre,
je vais réécrire cette formule
en disant que c'est racine de
une fois delta x au carré plus
une fois delta y au carré,
alors pourquoi je fais ça?
Eh bien imaginez un espace où cette formule
ne serait plus vraie,
un espace où pour calculer la distance
entre les deux points
on n'applique pas le théorème
de Pythagore,
mais une sorte de variante où à la place
la distance entre les points
ce serait disons racine de 1,3 delta x
au carré et plus 0,8 delta y au carré,
ça donnera une distance différente
entre les deux points,
mais notez bien, je ne touche pas
à la position des points dans l'espace,
ils ont les mêmes coordonnées x et y,
j'ai juste changé la manière de calculer
la distance à partir des coordonnées.
Alors là vous allez me dire "cette formule
en fait ça va pas, elle est fausse,
le théorème de Pythagore c'est pas ça".
Alors oui, elle est fausse dans un
espace qui n'est pas déformé,
mais dans un espace déformé, courbé,
eh bien c'est possible.
Un espace courbe on peut dire que c'est
en quelque sorte
un espace dans lequel le théorème de Pythagore
n'est plus forcément le même
et se trouve généralisé en mettant des
coefficients comme je viens de le faire.
Et de même qu'un espace peut être courbé
différemment suivant l'endroit,
eh bien les coefficients à utiliser
peuvent dépendre
de la région de l'espace
où on se trouve,
dans une région peu déformée ils seront
proches de 1 par exemple,
et dans les régions très déformées ils
peuvent être très différents.
Ces coefficients ça correspond en gros à ce
qu'on appelle la "métrique de l'espace".
Alors la métrique c'est l'ensemble
des coefficients
qui permettent de calculer les distances
dans un espace courbe
au moyen d'une sorte de
"théorème de Pythagore généralisé".
La métrique, c'est une notion géométrique
et qui va permettre de décrire
des espaces courbes, des espaces déformés
sans avoir forcément besoin de parler
de courbure,
et surtout sans avoir besoin
d'une dimension de plus
dans laquelle on serait obligé de représenter
cette courbure.
En changeant la métrique d'un espace
on déforme cet espace de façon intrinsèque s
ans avoir besoin d'un espace supplémentaire
au dessus donc en restant vraiment fidèle
à l'idée fondamentale de
la relativité générale
et en se débarrassant complètement des
espaces fixes et immuables.
La métrique, c'est vraiment l'objet central
des équations d'Einstein,
peut-être plus que la courbure,
et pour éviter les confusions
et les mauvaises interprétations,
c'est surtout de métrique que je vais parler
aujourd'hui, plutôt que de courbure.
Alors, petite précision importante:
là je vous ai donné un exemple d'espaces
en 2d, ça marche bien évidemment aussi en 3d,
mais surtout en relativité générale
on applique ces notions
pas seulement à l'espace, mais
à l'espace-temps donc en 4 dimensions,
et les équations de la relativité générale
permettent de décrire la façon
dont la métrique dépend de la masse
des objets présents
et donc varie dans l'espace et dans le temps.
Alors si vous avez du mal avec
cette idée d'espace
qu'on déforme uniquement en changeant
sa métrique,
laissez-moi vous présenter une autre
analogie,
un célèbre espace-temps très déformé:
le métro parisien.
Prenez une carte du métro parisien
et imaginez que vous ne soyez pas autorisé
à aller à la surface,
donc vous oubliez les rues, les avenues,
tout ça,
vous ne vous déplacez que
par les lignes de métro.
On peut s'amuser à mettre une grille sur la
carte et pour chaque station
à dire dans quelle case elle se trouve,
par exemple ici Gallieni se trouve en H4
alors que Mairie de Montreuil
se trouve en H5,
mais sur cette carte du métro pour calculer
les distances d'une station à une autre
vous ne pouvez pas faire à vol d'oiseau,
avec le théorème de Pythagore,
vous êtes obligé de vous conformer
aux lignes de métro,
et on pourrait penser initialement
que Mairie de Montreuil et Gallieni
ne sont pas très distantes, elles sont
dans deux cases voisines,
mais via le métro eh ben c'est compliqué,
on est obligé de faire deux correspondances
et de passer par la ligne 2,
donc ces deux stations, qui ont
des coordonnées proches,
sont en fait assez distantes,
c'est comme si l'espace-temps était très
courbé dans ce coin-là,
le métro c'est comme un espace muni
d'une métrique,
pour connaître la distance effective entre
deux points, entre deux stations,
on ne peut pas juste se baser sur le système
de coordonnées, la grille,
et faire du vol d'oiseau, il faut connaître
la métrique,
et deux points peuvent être proches dans
le système de coordonnées,
mais éloignés quand on prend en compte
la métrique.
Cette analogie du métro elle n'est pas
parfaite non plus,
mais c'est pour essayer de vous donner
un autre point de vue que le tissu déformé
pour appréhender ces notions
d'espace courbe
et puis pour vous montrer qu'on peut
déformer l'espace
sans forcément devoir le plonger dans
un espace fixe plus grand.
Alors quand Einstein formule sa théorie,
en 1915
il semblerait qu'il ait surtout en tête
des situations
où on a des déformations plutôt locales,
comme par exemple quand on a une étoile
massive et une planète qui va tourner autour,
mais a priori dans les équations rien
n'interdit
d'essayer de les appliquer
à l'univers tout entier,
ça paraît juste techniquement super compliqué
parce qu'il faudrait connaître
la masse, la position de chaque étoile,
sa vitesse de déplacement, etc.
Mais en 1927 un scientifique belge
Georges Lemaître décide quand même
d'appliquer les équations d'Einstein
à l'univers tout entier
et pour que ce soit faisable, il fait
une simplification dans les équations,
il suppose que l'univers est homogène.
Homogène ça veut dire qu'il est en gros
le même partout,
quel que soit le point on se trouve,
c'est évidemment faux
si vous vous trouvez près du soleil ce n'est
pas la même chose que loin du soleil,
voire carrément en dehors du système solaire.
En vrai l'univers n'est pas homogène,
mais vu de suffisamment loin, on peut faire
l'hypothèse qu'il le soit.
C'est comme l'air dans cette pièce,
vu de très près c'est pas un truc homogène,
si je zoome à fond je vais voir
qu'à certains endroits
il y a des molécules, N2, O2 etc.
et entre ces molécules, ben il n'y a rien.
Vu de loin on peut considérer l'air
ambiant comme un fluide homogène
et juste parler de sa densité moyenne
et ça permet de calculer des choses
et de comprendre certains phénomènes.
Eh bien, avec l'univers on peut faire
le même genre de raisonnement,
certes il y a des étoiles, des planètes,
mais supposons que, vu de loin,
on puisse considérer l'univers comme
un truc homogène,
une sorte de fluide ayant une certaine
densité qui soit la même en tout point,
en tout cas c'est cette hypothèse
que propose Georges Lemaître.
Et le fait de faire cette hypothèse
va énormément simplifier les équations
d'Einstein.
On a dit que, quand on veut parler de
la forme de l'espace-temps,
l'objet central a considérer c'est
la métrique,
les coefficients du théorème de Pythagore.
Si on considère l'univers comme homogène,
ça veut dire
que ces coefficients ils sont forcément
les mêmes partout
on ne se soucie pas de la façon
dont ça varierait,
dont l'univers serait plus ou moins courbé
à certains endroits,
non, on impose que la métrique soit
la même partout dans l'univers.
Si je reviens sur mon image en 2d
c'est comme
si on n'avait que deux coefficient
à déterminer
dans ma formule de Pythagore et qu'ils
soient valables partout.
Maintenant Lemaître fait une autre
hypothèse, assez intuitive,
il dit qu'il n'y a pas de raison
que ces deux coefficients soient différents.
L'axe x et l'axe y sont choisis de
façon arbitraire,
il n'y a pas de raison qu'ils se comportent
différemment, si c'était le cas,
ça voudrait dire que l'univers aurait
une sorte de direction privilégiée,
donc on va ajouter une hypothèse:
l'univers est le même
dans toutes les directions,
techniquement on parle de l'isotropie.
Et l'isotropie, ça impose que les coefficients
soient identiques dans tous les axes.
Avec ces hypothèses il n'y a qu'un seul
coefficient à connaître
pour caractériser la métrique
sur l'ensemble de l'univers,
c'est un simple coefficient en facteur
de la formule classique de Pythagore
donc là vous voyez qu'on a quand même
sacrément simplifié le truc
avec les hypothèses d'homogénéité
et d'isotropie.
Au départ on avait une sorte de
théorème de Pythagore généralisé
avec plein de coefficients qui pouvaient
varier partout dans l'univers
et là on a plus qu'un seul coefficient "a"
pour caractériser l'ensemble.
Ce coefficient il porte un nom, on l'appelle
le "facteur d'échelle" de l'univers,
si vous connaissez le facteur d'échelle
vous connaissez la métrique de l'univers.
Alors certes, le facteur d'échelle est
homogène, partout le même dans l'univers,
mais il y a quand même une subtilité,
il peut varier au cours du temps
et là que fait Georges Lemaître?
Eh bien il prend l'équation d'Einstein
et il regarde ce qu'il reste
une fois qu'on a fait toutes
ces simplifications
et il ne reste qu'une équation qui nous dit
comment le facteur d'échelle évolue
au cours du temps.
Pour celles et ceux qui ont fait
un peu de maths,
c'est une simple équation différentielle,
elle dépend de la densité moyenne
de l'univers,
et elle est très facile à résoudre,
même numériquement,
on peut faire ça avec Excel et
quand on la résout,
on trouve que le facteur d'échelle
augmente au cours du temps.
Qu'est ce que ça veut dire?
Eh bien revenons à mon image en 2d,
j'ai mes deux points ou
leurs coordonnées x y
et je calcule leur distance avec
le facteur d'échelle a,
maintenant si a augmente, eh bien
ça veut dire
que la distance entre les points augmente.
Attention les points n'ont pas vraiment
bougé dans l'espace,
ils sont toujours au même endroit
de la grille,
c'est juste la métrique qui a changé et donc
les points se retrouve plus éloignés
Alors c'est assez perturbant comme situation,
les points se retrouvent
plus éloignés qu'avant,
non pas parce qu'ils se sont déplacés
dans l'espace,
mais parce que la métrique de l'espace
elle-même a évolué
et Georges Lemaître arrive donc
à cette conclusion:
le facteur d'échelle de l'univers augmente.
Ça veut dire que tout s'éloigne de tout,
pas parce que les objets se déplacent les uns
par rapport aux autres dans l'espace,
mais parce que la métrique change,
l'espace se déforme, pour qualifier
ce phénomène
on parle traditionnellement
de "l'expansion de l'univers",
mais je veux utiliser ce mot d'expansion
avec prudence, et vous allez voir pourquoi.
Si on veut illustrer l'expansion
avec l'image de la toile en 2d,
on peut dire que c'est comme si on
tirait sur la toile pour la déformer,
comme si elle était élastique
et que donc
les objets de la grille se retrouvent
à s'éloigner les uns des autres
sans pour autant changer de position
sur la grille,
simplement sous l'effet de la
déformation de l'espace.
Alors vous voyez peut-être le problème
de cette image,
c'est qu'elle suppose, encore une fois,
d'avoir un espace fixe 3d,
immuable, à l'intérieur duquel
cette expansion se produit,
mais non, on n'a pas besoin de ça,
l'expansion de l'univers est
un truc intrinsèque
liée à l'évolution de la métrique,
donc l'univers ne "s'étend pas"
dans quelque chose,
sa métrique change, et d'ailleurs, ça ne dit
rien de la taille de l'univers,
le raisonnement fonctionne indépendamment
du fait que l'univers soit fini ou infini,
si on veut se représenter cette sorte
d'expansion avec l'analogie du métro,
c'est comme si les stations restaient
à leur place,
mais que les lignes de métro changeaient,
devenaient de plus en plus tortueuse
ou de plus en plus lente,
ce qui fait que la distance effective
entre les stations augmenterait
en permanence sans que leur position
sur la grille ne change.
Avec ses calculs Georges Lemaître arrive
donc à cette conclusion perturbante:
"la métrique de l'univers change",
l'univers se déforme en permanence
et tout se passe comme s'il était
en expansion
et que donc tous les objets de l'univers
s'éloignaient les uns des autres.
Alors évidemment, en faisant ce raisonnement
Lemaître avait en tête les observations de
Vesto Slipher
qui montrait que la plupart des galaxies
semblaient s'éloigner de nous.
Les calculs de Lemaître prédisaient
que la vitesse apparente d'éloignement
d'une galaxie devait être
proportionnelle à la distance qui nous
sépare et d'elle.
Quelques années plus tard, en 1929, Edwin
Hubble réalise une campagne d'observation
de plusieurs nébuleuses et galaxies
dont il mesure la distance
et la vitesse d'éloignement, et là bingo!
il trouve une relation de proportionnalité,
comme l'avait prédit Georges Lemaître.
Le graphique que vous voyez ici est celui
qu'avait réalisé Hubble en 1929,
en observant une vingtaine de nébuleuses
situées à maximum quelques millions
d'années lumière,
en abscisse vous avez la distance estimée
et en ordonnée la vitesse d'éloignement,
plus la distance augmente
plus la vitesse augmente,
et il y à bien une vague relation de
proportionnalité entre les deux.
Alors, aujourd'hui on sait faire évidemment
beaucoup mieux, voici un exemple,
toujours distances en abscisse
et vitesses en ordonnée,
le petit carré rouge dans le coin en bas
à gauche ça correspond
à la zone dans laquelle se trouvent
les observations initiales de Hubble,
mais ici les mesures ont été faites
jusqu'à plusieurs centaines
de millions d'années lumière
et vous voyez que ça marche hyper bien,
on a une belle relation de proportionnalité, l
a vitesse est proportionnelle à la distance
et en hommage à Hubble
on note H le coefficient de proportionnalité,
dont on sait assez bien estimer
la valeur aujourd'hui.
Notez tout de même que depuis 2018
la loi de proportionnalité
s'appelle maintenant officiellement
la Loi de Hubble-Lemaître,
oui il faut quand même rappeler
que Georges Lemaître l'avait prédite
plusieurs années avant.
Un petit détail quand même, là on
parle uniquement
de l'augmentation des distances due
à l'évolution de la métrique,
la dilatation de la grille si
vous voulez,
et en plus de ça les galaxies peuvent
se déplacer dans l'espace.
C'est le cas par exemple de notre
plus proche voisine la galaxie d'Andromède,
elle se rapproche de nous, elle se déplace
sur la grille
et comme elle est proche de nous
l'effet d'évolution de la métrique
est assez négligeable,
donc cette galaxie en particulier
s'approche de nous et,
à cause de l'effet Doppler, elle possède un
décalage vers le bleu, pas vers le rouge.
Mais dès qu'on regarde des galaxies
suffisamment lointaines,
l'expansion de l'univers est largement
dominante et tout s'éloigne de nous.
Bien, donc l'univers est en expansion,
les galaxies s'éloignent les unes des autres
et on sait calculer à quel rythme,
on peut donc calculer
à quelle distance elles se trouveront
dans un million d'années,
un milliard d'années, 10 milliards d'années
etc.,
on peut prévoir l'avenir et l'évolution
de l'univers
Alors c'est très facile avec l'équation
de Lemaître,
voici ce qu'on obtient, en abscisse vous
avez le temps
qui s'écoule à partir de maintenant,
donc on part de zéro
et en ordonnée l'évolution du facteur
d'échelle.
Une chose qui vous surprend peut-être
c'est de voir qu'à T égal zéro
qui correspond à "en ce moment", le facteur
d'échelle est exactement égal à 1,
en fait ça n'a rien d'étonnant,
c'est fait exprès,
c'est parce que le facteur d'échelle
est uniquement un truc relatif
donc on peut, par convention, le fixer à 1
pour le temps présent
et calculer son évolution dans l'avenir.
Et ce qu'on voit c'est que par exemple
dans dix milliards d'années
il vaudra pas loin de 2 c'est-à-dire
que toutes les distances dans l'univers
auront en gros doublé par rapport
à aujourd'hui.
Cette idée que l'univers puisse évoluer
comme ça de façon globale,
cette expansion de l'univers est déjà
assez perturbante,
mais quelques années plus tard, en 1931,
Georges Lemaître décide
de pousser le bouchon encore plus loin,
il ne se contente plus de prédire
l'avenir de l'univers,
mais il rembobine le film
et reconstitue son passé.
[Musique]
La première chose qu'il faut dire c'est que
cette idée de rembobiner l'histoire
de l'univers, elle n'a,
a priori, rien d'incongru hein,
c'est très facile en physique
d'utiliser les équations à l'envers
pour rembobiner.
Prenons un exemple en mécanique classique,
newtonienne,
si on considère un boulet de canon
dont on connaît la position
et la vitesse on peut prédire son mouvement,
son avenir,
mais on peut aussi très bien rembobiner
et reconstituer sa trajectoire passée
il n'y a aucun problème.
Eh bien avec l'équation d'évolution du
facteur d'échelle on peut faire pareil,
on peut remonter le temps pour savoir
comment il était dans le passé.
Et c'est ce qu'a fait Georges Lemaître
en 1931,
et pareil ça se fait très bien numériquement
même avec un simple tableur,
je vais juste le faire avec les valeurs
modernes des constantes
qu'on utilise dans l'équation.
Alors allons-y, si on rembobine l'histoire
du facteur d'échelle
à partir d'aujourd'hui, voici ce qu'on trouve.
Je remets la courbe de tout à l'heure
pour l'évolution dans l'avenir,
et cette fois on va remonter dans le temps
donc toujours en prenant par convention
T égal zéro pour l'instant présent.
Le facteur d'échelle vaut donc 1 aujourd'hui
et si on remonte dans le temps,
eh bien on voit que dans le passé il était
de plus en plus faible, c
e qui indique que les distances
entre les galaxies
étaient plus petites qu'aujourd'hui.
On peut calculer qu'en conséquence de ça
la densité de l'univers était plus élevée
ainsi que sa température.
Et plus on remonte, plus le facteur
d'échelle diminue,
plus la densité et la
température augmente,
il y à 8 milliards d'années les distances
étaient la moitié
de ce qu'elles sont aujourd'hui, il y a
dix milliards d'années c'était un tiers,
il y à 13 milliards d'années c'était un
dixième, jusqu'à…
Eh bien jusqu'à ce qu'on trouve
qu'il y à 13,8 milliards d'années
le facteur d'échelle était nul, la
température était infinie
et toutes les distances valaient 0.
Le Big Bang, la naissance de l'univers!
Alors est-ce qu'on a droit de dire ça?
Ben, pas vraiment hein.
Rembobiner l'histoire de l'univers, OK,
mais rembobiner jusqu'au moment où le facteur
d'échelle est exactement 0
et donc la densité infinie, non!
Il faut bien voir que quand on rembobine,
on utilise des équations
et on suppose donc que les équations
sont valides, applicables.
Revenons à mon exemple du boulet de canon,
si je rembobine sa trajectoire je peux être
confiant un moment,
mais quand j'arrive pas loin du sol
ben je n'ai plus le droit d'extrapoler,
les équations que j'utilise prennent
uniquement en compte la gravité,
mais elles ne sont pas applicables
pour comprendre comment il a été lancé,
par un canon, par une catapulte,
depuis une tour,
est-ce qu'il est sorti du sol?
Donc j'ai le droit de rembobiner,
mais je sais que quand je m'approche du
sol, il faut que j'arrête.
Alors je peux continuer à faire
comme s'il avait émergé du sol,
mais il faut que je sois conscient
qu'on n'en sait rien.
Eh bien le Big Bang, c'est un peu pareil,
on sait en rembobinant les équations
qu'il y a eu une période très dense
et très chaude,
il y a environ 13,8 milliards d'années,
mais est-ce qu'il y a eu un instant 0?
Eh ben on n'en sait rien car quand la densité
et la température deviennent trop élevées
on sait que les équations qu'on utilise
deviennent certainement fausses.
D'ailleurs pour les scientifiques,
le terme Big Bang ne désigne pas tellement
l'instant zéro,
mais plutôt une période, cette phase
très dense et très chaude
qu'il y a eu sans préjuger de ce qu'il
s'est passé exactement au tout tout début.
D'un point de vue historique il faut
bien préciser
que ces travaux de Georges Lemaître
c'était en 1931
et que ça n'a pas été tellement accueilli
avec faveur par les scientifiques de l'époque.
Il faut dire que Lemaître n'était pas
seulement physicien,
c'était aussi un prêtre catholique,
et pour pas mal de gens
cette histoire de début de l'univers avait
un goût beaucoup trop créationniste.
Le terme même de "Big Bang" était d'ailleurs
au départ une moquerie
inventé par un adversaire de la théorie,
l'astrophysicien Fred Hoyle.
Ce dernier acceptait parfaitement l'expansion
de l'univers,
le décalage vers le rouge tout ça, mais
il refusait le modèle du Big Bang
et préférait un autre modèle qui supposait
une création continue de matière
et donc pas de phase dense et chaude.
Depuis le modèle du Big Bang a été
totalement accepté
par la communauté scientifique
et il faut dire
qu'on en a trouvé de nombreuses confirmations
dans les observations astrophysiques.
Ces confirmations correspondent
aux différentes étapes
de l'évolution l'univers et je vais
en faire une revue rapide
sans trop entrer dans les détails.
Pour positionner tout ça on va prendre
une chronologie de l'univers
et on va juste faire un truc un peu bizarre,
on va la faire démarrer autour
de l'instant zéro,
alors c'est bizarre parce que
je vous ai bien expliqué
qu'on n'avait pas de certitudes sur
ce qui s'était vraiment passé,
mais ça ne nous empêche pas de compter
à partir de ce moment-là
et pour reconstituer ce à quoi pouvait
ressembler la matière
au cours de l'évolution de l'univers,
eh bien on se base sur l'évolution
de la température et de la densité
et sur ce que l'on sait de la physique
des particules.
On pense par exemple qu'à environ
une nanosecondes
il faisait dans les un million de milliards
de degrés
et les quarks se sont formés puis l'univers
s'est suffisamment refroidi
pour que se forment notamment les protons
et les neutrons,
et à environ 3 minutes, en dessous
du milliard de degrés
ceux ci ont commencé à s'assembler pour
constituer les premiers noyaux
comme l'hélium et un peu de lithium,
on parle de nucléosynthèse primordiale.
Cette étape est très importante car
le modèle du Big Bang
prédit un certain ratio pour la quantité
d'hélium produit
par rapport à l'hydrogène, environ 25%,
d'hélium,
or c'est bien ce ratio qu'on observe
aujourd'hui dans l'univers
donc l'abondance relative de l'hélium
est une preuve forte
de la nucléosynthèse primordiale
et une confirmation de cette étape
du modèle du Big Bang.
Un peu plus tard, après 380 000 ans environ,
il ne faisait plus "que" 3000 kelvin,
les électrons se sont associés aux noyaux
pour former les premiers atomes
et de cette époque, qu'on appelle
la recombinaison,
il reste un vestige qui est le rayonnement
du fond diffus cosmologique,
le rayonnement fossile, sa découverte
expérimentale en 1964
par Penzias et Wilson a été LE grand moment
de confirmation du modèle du big bang,
alors je ne vous en parle pas plus,
j'ai fait un long épisode sur le sujet.
Parmi les autres confirmations expérimentales
il y a aussi la manière dont sont réparties
les galaxies dans l'univers,
ce qu'on appelle "la structure à grande
échelle de l'univers",
la structure qu'on observe aujourd'hui
correspond bien à ce qu'on attend
d'un univers ayant subi une période chaude
et dense et soumis
à des fluctuations extrêmement légères
de densité,
dont les galaxies sont en quelque sorte
les conséquences
C'est un long sujet je ferai peut-être
un épisode dédié un jour.
Pour conclure vous voyez qu'il existe
plusieurs confirmations expérimentales
très solides pour venir appuyer
le modèle du Big Bang
et ça me permet de terminer par un point
de vocabulaire:
on parle généralement de
la "théorie" du Big Bang,
j'ai d'ailleurs certainement moi même utilisé
le mot aujourd'hui.
Dans le langage de tous les jours
le terme "théorie" est parfois employé
pour un truc pour lequel
on n'a aucune preuve,
du genre "ah ouais, mais c'est juste
une théorie".
Mais en physique, le mot théorie
ça désigne simplement
une description formalisé d'un phénomène,
un modèle,
ça veut pas du tout dire
qu'on n'a pas de preuve,
donc quand on parle de la "théorie
du Big Bang"
c'est pas du tout pour dire
qu'on n'en sait rien,
on a au contraire énormément
de connaissances
qui nous permettent de reconstituer de
façon précise l'histoire de l'univers,
sauf la question de l'instant zéro.
Pour comprendre ce qu'il a pu se passer dans
la période la plus chaude et la plus dense
il faudrait disposer d'un modèle
prenant en compte
la relativité générale et
la mécanique quantique.
C'est quelque chose qu'on ne sait pas
encore faire aujourd'hui
et je vous renvoie à mes différents
épisodes sur le sujet.
Voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui,
j'espère que ça vous éclaire
et que ça dissipe quelques malentendus
que vous pourriez avoir
sur ce qu'est le Big Bang,
s'il reste des doutes, je vous renvoie
à mon billet de blog
qui comme toujours complète la vidéo,
le lien est dans la description.
Abonnez vous, mettez la cloche,
partagez la vidéo
pour m'aider à faire connaître tout ça
et je vous dis à très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos.
À bientôt
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -